warhammer 40 000 road trader is the
first game of its kind to exist in the
40k universe but what does it mean for
rogue trader and for warhammer games as
a whole i caught up with alexander gusev
the creative director for road trader at
owlcat games to find out a little more
about warhammer 40k's first crpg what
it's offering to warhammer fans the
game's characters the setting of rogue
trader and more one of the key things is
that in the world of 40k rogue trader
dynasties have an incredible amount of
freedom due to their warrant of trade
this is a letter of appointment that
elevates their authority to that that
may sometimes equal space marines and
even planetary governors some were even
signed by the emperor himself this
incredible freedom within the 40k
universe can now translate to the
freedom of the player you can go to
places where other people really go
you're also given more freedom than
almost anyone within the setting you're
also given more freedom and how you
interact with others like for example
most imperial servants will
only be able to interact with zenith in
the way of killing them while you can
actually talk to them and it is
not completely heresy alexander alluded
to some of the potential party members
that may be available to you in your
travels and only accessible due to your
freedom and status while i was told most
of your party would be human in nature
some are
less human than others there are
individuals such as a space marine a
sister of battle and navigator of the
war a selection of psyches both
sanctioned and unsanctioned but when it
comes to fully non-human xenos party
members concerning non-human races there
are elderly ranger featured on the gear
and that's not not the only zenith
companion you will have now what those
races could be we may have to wait a
little while to find out perhaps a crew
mercenary maybe a squat to tie in with
games workshop's release of leagues of
voltan or maybe even a jokero companion
i'm looking forward to reading your
theories in the comment section below
but who are these characters going to be
who are you going to be i asked about
things like classes and careers and how
your rogue trade will start and grow
through your campaign alex said that
they have a career system that will
reflect both the background of your
character but also the abilities
available to you as you level up through
the game in the lore of warhammer many
rogue traders start off as members of
the imperial guard navy merchants
planetary commanders or even in rare
cases part of the inquisition with these
concept artworks that alka shared with
me we know of at least two potential
backgrounds a commissar and a crime lord
with no doubt many more to come how this
connects to your ancestor theodora the
individual we saw in the trailer we
don't yet know only that you are her
heir but potentially not the most direct
descendant or even first choice to take
up the mantle of rogue trader it appears
then that this rogue-traded dynasty was
created and has thrived way before your
character's status was elevated and
therefore there's both a ship under your
command and worlds under your influence
your ship is a giant cathedral fortress
factory so there will be some adventures
within the ship itself about the dynasty
the most important part the dynasty
gives you is the third trade empire
within corona expense it has some walls
within it one of them for example is
janus it's a world covered in jungle
that was uh repurposed because of its
plant life it was reversed proposed for
agriculture and uh well currently it is
in
some sort of trouble i i cannot really
delve into it right now another world
that is under your protection is a
forged wolf that is actually uh under
mechanicus rule but uh
it is within your trade empire so you
have some relationship with it you will
have your capital where you will
interact with some
noble houses that were given titles uh
by different members of your dynasty but
for example i mentioned the forge world
within your within your empire it is up
to you to choose what will be produced
there and
some of the things that you can decide
to produce here
are not as legal
or
as
loyal to the imperium several things
that we consider to be serpg
cornerstones one of them are companions
when we mention crpg we always
mean it to be companion focused so we
will have companions and those companies
will not be just
units that travel with you and
they will have their stories they will
have their dialogues they will interrupt
your uh dialogues and add things that
they think they can disagree with you
and sometimes these disagreements can
become violent and they can also
disagree with each other there are
tensions between some factions are quite
high so as you might imagine for example
adapter serratus or
space marine can
be quite
wary of zenith in your party another
thing that we consider to be inherent
part of what rpg is
is uh basically playing with your role
having your role not being just a thing
you assume during your during your
playthrough but the things that you can
play with so you can define it you can
change it and this means that we want
your choices to really matter to change
who you are how people react to you and
so there will be numerous places within
the game where you can change the way uh
the world will work from now sometimes
in mineral issues sometimes in more
major no other warhammer 40 000 game has
boasted this much choice freedom
exploration or interaction with its
universe but with the extra depth the
crpg allows comes the risk of players
that are new to the franchise feeling
overwhelmed or lost within webs of lore
and buzzwords this has often been an
issue and it's come to me pitching
warhammer 40 000 to my friends that
might be interested but it appears that
owlcat has similar thoughts and are
building this game with both depth and
approachability in mind when it comes to
players exploring the rogue trade as
corona's expanse the imperial presence
there exists but it isn't
as complete as within other sectors so
there are still places to explore still
places to find stuff that wasn't uh
seen by humans warhammer lore while it
is expansive and deep in places is not
open to
normal citizen within the imperium
basically the lower you are in your
station the less you will actually know
this ties greatly into our idea of
explaining it to you because at the
start of the game you're uh just living
in the on the ship basically and from
this on onwards with can we explain to
you first what rogue trader is
what exactly is happening at all there
then we can explain like how imperium
works uh then we can explain what zenas
chaos and so on and delve deeper and
deeper into some things rogue trader
seems to want to allow players to
experience more than the combat and war
of warhammer 40 000. while battles and
bloodshed will still be a core part of
the game as with any other crpg the
genre allows the other parts of life in
the 41st millennium to shine a little
brighter for those stories to be told
and those characters and archetypes to
be fleshed out in a way that may not
have been possible in a game that's set
primarily on a battlefield people who
are not delving deep into warhammer lore
that this is like a setting only about
war where like space marine skill works
and nothing else basically happens it's
always world war and uh and they just
assume that the setting kind of makes no
sense while people who like read black
library books they know that there are
forge worlds where all this stuff has
produced high walls where billions
of people live and where the armies of
imperium are grown and trained it's not
exactly about the lack of war it's more
about there's also other stuff it gets
to explore uh like an uninhabited world
graveyards of civilizations it gets to
explore
how frontier works how planets get into
imperium how it happened that imperium
spans a whole galaxy it's because of
people basically like you these are
pretty lofty goals for warhammer 40000's
first crpg but if our cat can accomplish
them then rogue trader will allow
players to interact and explore the
universe of 40k in a way that we've just
not seen before and hopefully in a way
that will appeal to both the die hard
fans of the collection of black library
books and piles of plastic to those who
are just first entering into the world
of 40k to the people who want the
intense combat and to see a space marine
in action or even to the players out
there who want to see what 40k is life
beyond the barrel of a bulk in the grim
dark future there may only be war
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
anything else
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed and can tell i'm very
excited about this game if you are as
well let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below or tweet me at a
regular dave make sure to like the video
subscribe for more like this and i'll
see you in the next one
[Music]